what wins this matchup a 300 million
dollar roller coaster or a ride based on
the cat in the hat the answer could
surprise you
but the real surprise is how low the
incredible hulk coaster is on this list
the wait times for storm forest
acceleron aren't usually too bad but
that's only because people are spending
their time doing other things
it's not an awful experience it's an
acceptable family-friendly teacup clone
even if it's a bit more dizzying than it
needs to be but it doesn't make for a
memorable time either and while you're
waiting for it to end in your spinning
seat with your chin and your palm you'll
have plenty of time to think about all
the better x-men rides that could have
been don't waste your time unless you've
hit everything else first pteranodon
flyers isn't a bad ride in and of itself
the problem the ride is simply too
restrictive as only two riders can use
pteranodon flyers at a time one in front
of the other and one of them has to be a
kid too this means a you have to have or
be a kid to begin with b writers can't
sit next to each other and experience
flyers together and c larger families
are separated for the duration and have
to wait for the rest of the group at one
of the three confusingly arranged exits
this also leads to childless park
visitors being unnecessarily turned away
from the ride there just wasn't quite
enough thought put into this one your
scientists were so preoccupied with
whether or not they could they didn't
stop to think if they should
on one fish two fish redfish bluefish
riders can move their little cartoon
fish cars up and down as they swing
around in a circle the views of seuss
landing are colorful and fun but they
can be a bit distracting that's because
if you don't pay attention to the riot's
catchy jingle which subtly tells you
when and how to move your car there's a
chance you'll get splashed with a little
stream of water it's a memorable little
mechanism but we can also see how it'd
be a reason for parents to take their
kids on other drier rides
kitty coasters have a tendency to get
overlooked but flight of the hippogriff
in the wizarding world of harry potter
section of islands of adventure might be
worth a visit if you've got kids young
enough to enjoy it it takes you through
the forbidden forest past hagrid's hut
and up to buckbeak the titular magical
creature before looping back around the
track is predictably tame although there
are some mildly unexpected twists that
can force a smile out of you along the
way and the views of hogwarts castle are
spectacular
space shot rides definitely aren't for
everyone they're the ones where you get
shot up to the top of a tower and then
dropped rapidly usually in controlled
bursts broken up with air cushions for a
stop and start thrill experience doctor
doom's fearfall is one of the better
ones thanks to a fun cue that gets you
into the story the problem you'd better
love that cue because this is a long
wait for a very short ride so only check
this one out if you have time to spare
the carrow sioux cell is exactly what it
sounds like a carousel ride where the
horses have been swapped out for dr
seuss characters it's good family
friendly fun with a relatively short
wait time and a catchy little jingle and
if you push on the levers on the
character's necks or pull on their reins
you can animate them giving this one an
extra little bit of fun
the cat's iconic hat towers above seuss
landing and can be fairly easily seen
from adjacent areas of the park the ride
itself is certainly well put together
it's a track that takes you through a
dimly lit twisting hallway filled with
iconic scenes from the classic
children's book there is the talking
fish thing one and thing two lots of
crazy furniture to look at and much more
and of course the cat makes plenty of
appearances throughout the main problem
with the ride is that it's too scary for
small kids and too boring for adults but
if you're the exact right age in between
you might enjoy it a lot
dudley do right's ripsaw falls ride
isn't an essential stop but it can be a
fun way for the family to beat the muggy
florida heat with laughs and a whole lot
of water the queue is fun and the ride
provides an iconic 75 foot plunge into
the water below the climax of the ride
leaves nobody dry
anyone who doesn't feel like getting
soaked can still have fun with the ride
you just have to stand by and watch
people get drenched or you can pay a
small fee and shoot them yourself with
water turrets
poseidon's fury is at least as much fun
for the theater kid playing the
archaeologist tour guide as it is for
the families experiencing it the idea is
that the guide needs your help
navigating the temple of poseidon which
is under attack from an evil dark lord
there's a great mix of physical set
pieces that someone clearly had a blast
building and digital effects that bring
it all to life with the help of your
animated thoroughly entertaining guide
there are spooky moments but nothing
sudden or shocking that parents of young
tykes need to concern themselves with as
of january 2022 the ride is closed but
there are reports that it will open back
up in the very near future there are
raft rides and log flumes in just about
any major theme park including several
others at universal studios itself but
what sets jurassic park river adventure
apart is something that on paper would
make it sound rather lame education
you lazily cruise past massive life-size
animatronic dinos while a narrator fills
you in on the details of the real thing
think of it as a time traveling boat
tour and if you're not into learning no
worries there's also an enormous 85 foot
plunge at the end that will soak
everyone on the ride it's the best of
both worlds
high above the family-oriented fun of
sue's landing you'll find the high in
the sky seuss trolley train ride which
takes families through seuss-styled
circus tents and houses filled with all
the weird wacky colorful creatures and
contraptions you'd expect in such places
they could have easily put a ride like
this on the ground but instead they
elevated it so the outdoor stretches in
between the ride set pieces offer
spectacular views all in all it's a fun
silly colorful relaxing way to spend a
few minutes with the kids while everyone
takes a breather and plans the next stop
popeye and bluto's bilge rat barges is a
great way for families to beat the
florida heat and kill an hour or two
just pile into a big circular float and
drift downstream past plenty of colorful
set pieces classic old school popeye
characters and other parts of toon
lagoon it probably won't be anyone's
favorite ride but wait times are short
and anyone willing to get a little wet
will have fun plus it's a nice way to
quickly explore a fun but neglected part
of the park that you probably won't be
spending too much time in otherwise
this is simply one of the best trackless
theme park rides in the world riders
board a safari truck and get taken on a
perilous journey through a spooky dark
pacific island based on peter jackson's
2005 king kong movie the ride blends
digital and physical effects to magical
levels there are bats giant bugs spooky
caves bones everywhere and a huge fight
between kong and a giant dinosaur that
sends your car reeling and crashing over
cliffs it's an unforgettable experience
truly worthy of the flagship status it's
created for itself at the park
this one's a bit weird because it's only
half in islands of adventure but that's
the whole point hop on the iconic train
from the harry potter world there and
ride it to the other original half of
universal studios or vice versa it
functions more like a shuttle than a
ride even so though the experience is
almost as cool as the hogsmeade and
diagon alley park sections which bookend
it that's because it's not just
decorated like the express on the inside
you get a digital display on the windows
that makes it look like you're traveling
through the wizarding world we see in
the films just hold on to your chocolate
frogs
watch it
the queue and the visible set pieces
around jurassic park's veloci coaster
are all about velociraptors everyone's
favorite dinosaurs ever since jurassic
park made them famous so there's plenty
of those to see and hear as you move
through the line eventually you'll get
to the coaster though and to say it
makes the rather underwhelming q
experience worth it is an understatement
prepare for high speeds killer loops and
twists and big fast drops it's as solid
a roller coaster as you're likely to
find just about anywhere and a must ride
for first timers to universal and repeat
visitors alike
the incredible hulk coaster is perhaps
the most iconic universal studios ride
there is luckily it's also one of the
first things you'll get to do upon
entering the park unsurprisingly the
weight is long given how easy the
coaster is to reach and how popular it
is but universal pulled out all the
stops to deck out the queue with blaring
lights sirens and cool comic bookie
sci-fi gizmos so don't worry about
getting bored on the way up and the ride
itself is worth the wait appropriately
enough it's a powerful angry green beast
that plunges you into epic drops and
launches you into loops and twists at
thrilling speeds
we will say this though while the ride
isn't necessarily too extreme for most
theme park enthusiasts it's definitely a
good idea to grab a bite to eat after
you get off and not before
towering over islands of adventure and
visible from several remote areas of the
park is hogwarts itself the iconic
castle school from the harry potter
films it's a good thing that it takes so
long to get to because it builds
anticipation throughout the day and
keeps everyone in your group excited to
get to the next place the recreated town
of hogsmeade is just below and offers an
incredible immersive experience for
harry potter fans and everyone else
alike but the forbidden journey is the
real draw here a massive 4d flying
adventure where you follow harry himself
on a dizzying dazzling flight through
the school grounds and away from dragons
and dementors the wait time can be
absolutely excruciating but thanks to
the ride and the chance to explore the
castle we've never heard of anyone
regretting this one-of-a-kind experience
it's hard to make a better more
thrilling more impressive 4d movie
experience than the amazing adventures
of spider-man the queue is almost as
memorable as the ride itself allowing
you to check out the inside of the daily
bugle the iconic fictional newspaper
that peter parker worked at that's where
grumpy editor jay jonah jameson recruits
the guests to get the scoop on the
latest super villain attack the ride
itself throws you into the thick of it
alongside spidey in his fight against
the sinister syndicate led by dr octopus
it pulls out all the stops to make it
seem real lighting effects wind blasts
simulator movements and more and keep
your eyes out for a cameo by the great
stan lee they've even added me to the 3d
adventure but i'm not going to tell you
where to find me you'll have to discover
that on your own
the best ride at islands of adventure is
none other than hagrid's magical
creatures motorbike adventure a 300
million dollar behemoth of a coaster
that opened in 2019 in which the titular
character takes you through a maze of
epic harry potter set pieces filled with
three-headed dogs unicorns and other
magical creatures that roam the woods
around hogwarts it's a good thing the
ride is so great too because when it
opened wait times often exceeded 8 hours
the massive height for the ride set a
brutally high bar but it's safe to say
that the coaster reached it and then
some check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite theme parks are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you